Chương miệng tháng cám, báo nhân dân vào y bán nhân dân thành phố Hồ Chí Minh,
công bố chương trình nghệ thuật chính luận tổ Quốc trong piên 2 ngày tổ chẳng ngày sau.
Chương trình dân ra và lúc 2 ngày dân ngày 3 tháng cám tại Cô Đồ Thì và Cô Siti,
thành phố Hồ Chí Minh với thông biệt, tổ Quốc trẳng ở đâu ra, tổ Quốc là trong pi mũ người.
Khiếp nối thành công của một đầu tiên tại Hà Nội năm 2019,
chương trình năm nay được đầu thương pi mồ lớn hơn,
kết hợp âm nhạc, sân khẩu và công nghệ trình dễn,
mà lỗi dung gồm bà chương, ngon xơ một dài sách nó thương hao và tổ Quốc trong piên,
kể những công chuyện về lịch sử bán hoá con người Việt Nam và tính yêu thu Quốc,
chương trình quy tủ nhỏ nghệ sự ý thuật khác thể hệ nhiều kệ sinh tủ cà mình,
kệ sinh tủ đăng duân tổng vương sau biến, nước thức thịk,
khoa minh dưỡng, đường tràm, mở hạch châm của nhỏ nghệ sự chè,
lỗi dung buổi biểu viến được hết con thành bà chương nghệ thuật,
nóng xô một dài, giữa lại hành xin dấu tranh dành được lập thống nhất đất nước,
và những giá chị được đánh bối bằng sự hiết sinh của các thế hệ người Việt Nam.
Sắp bỏ từ hào, lấy hình cửa là cửa tổ khóc làm sự chỉ đó,
vừa chương tròn nhiều mưu hãng, ý chị và tình thần đoàn kết dân tộc.
Khép lại, tổ khúc trong tiêm mang mồ sắc khả chúng, hiện nay,
kết nối các giá chị vàng hóa mà miền,
lãng tỏa tình như thương, nhiều mưu hào rất tộc đến với thế hệ hụi này.
Hình đường là cửa đỏ sau vang, kết tục được sự dụng xuyên xuất từ hệ thống nhận dịch,
không dân xanh câu đến những khoảng khắc có sự thăm ra của công chúng.
Chờ thành sự dây kết nối, các lúc giữa yếu ở lịch sử mới đổi sống hông này.
Đáng xuyi, chương trình có sự thăm ra của phủy đại dễn quân đội nhân dân Việt Nam và cơ quan nhân dân.
Chông đó có lực lượng dịn dữ hòa bình Việt Nam và cạnh sát dữ hòa bình liên hật quốc.
Mình cạnh xanh câu trình tại vản phúc CT, không dân phân đâm yêu nước tại phủy bộ mến hệ sẽ tổ chức các hoạt động raul liều tránh giận dành cho công chúng.
Chương trình được phát triếp trên các mênh tảng số của báo nhân dân và các cây chính thức của tổ chức trong tiêm.
Con bộ vẻ thăm dữ được phát mẹn phí.
Tại buổi công bố, đồng chiếc lấy cúc mêng, bởi viên trung đảng tổ miếp tập báo nhân dân.
Bỏ trường bán trình giáo trung lân, chú tịch hội nhà báo Việt Nam cho biết.
Bán nhân dân định hướng tưởng bất phát triển tổ quốc trong tiêm thành một ai phía văn hoá.
Người thuật, măng tầm cú ra, lấy trưng trên người thuật chính luật làm sản phẩm hàng nhân.
Để phát triển các sản phẩm và hoạt động văn hoá có giá trị lâu dài.
Chương trình hướng tới trở thành một diểm hẹn văn hoá thượng liên.
Nơi nghệ thuật kể câu chuyển Việt Nam bằng ngôn nữ thời đại.
Đồng thời có phần đổi mới phương thức chuyên chuyên.
Ráo dục chuyển thống yêu nước và tạo thêm những sản phẩm văn hoá có chất lượng.
Có sức lăn hoá.
Tổ quốc trong tiêm thành nghiệp trong hay sấu gó báo nhân dân.
Bởi bán nhân dân thành vố hổ chí mêng của hợp tổ chức.